PROFESSOR: So in order to use
our results for the analysis
of the well-mixed room
into the safety guideline,
let me just
summarize the results
for the general case of
transient build-up of aerosols
in the room and the
associated transmission.
So here is the result
that we derived
earlier, which is
that the transmission
rate as a function of time is
an integral over all the droplet
sizes.
And then you have here the
mask filtration factor,
which depends on size P_m.
You have the
breathing rate Q_b that
comes in squared because there's
one person breathing out,
another person breathing in.
You got the volume of the room.
You have here the
relaxation rate
for the concentration
of aerosol in the room,
which here is given by four
factors for ventilation,
sedimentation, filtration,
and deactivation.
And then for the
production of aerosols,
there's this n_q(r), which is
the number of exhaled infection
quanta per volume,
per air volume leaving
the breath per radius
because it's still resolved
by the different droplet radii.
And this has several
contributions.
It has n_d(r), which is the
distribution of droplet sizes.
V_d(r) is the volume
of each droplet.
Depends on the
respiratory activity.
C_v is the viral load,
which we are typically
assuming is near the
maximum when we're concerned
about controlling spreading.
And C_i(r) is the
infectivity per virion,
which we have discussed before
also may have a size dependence
and is most likely higher
in the aerosol droplets.
So that's the general solution.
And the safety guideline
we just discussed
has in it the time average beta,
so beta with the two brackets,
which is the integral in time
of beta divided by the time tau.
So you break that
into two parts.
So we integrate this here.
The one here is--
it gives you a
steady state term,
and the interval is
shown right here.
And that's basically the--
ultimately the average
that remains, but initially
when the infected person
first walks in the room,
there's a time to build up
the concentration, which only
lowers the transmission rate.
So the average
transmission rate is always
less than the steady state.
You're approaching
the steady state
from below because you
need the time to build up
those droplets.
And so the DELTA beta here,
which is that correction,
takes the following form.
What you can do is bring the
interval over time and switch
places with the
integration over r
and do the time integral
inside the integral.
And so that allows you to
get-- instead of lambda_c here,
you get lambda_c
squared, and you
get the following expression
for the DELTA beta.
It may not be obvious
looking at it,
but if you take a look
at tau going to 0,
this expression leads
to just beta bar.
So DELTA beta of 0 is
beta bar, and that's
because if you take
this exponential here
and you go to small times, you
can linearize that and find
its lambda_c t.
So it factors--
cancels one factor
of lambda_c, one factor
of tau, and you end up
with just a single
lambda_c as above.
So what that means is that
the average beta, which
we're plotting here, as a
function of the time tau
starts out at 0.
It ramps up and then eventually
approaches a steady state,
and here's the full solution.
So all the
information that we've
talked about before in terms
of filtration, sedimentation,
other phenomena in
the well-mixed room
are all included
in this framework
and can then be put into
the safety guideline
to derive a general
safety guideline that
has all of the physics
that we want in there
and allows you to define a
safe occupancy for a room.